Game of Thrones is back after the longest
off-season ever, and Episode 1 of Season 7
sets the stage for the conflicts ahead.
Arya is at the Twins, wearing the face of
Walder Frey – who she killed last season.
It’s not clear exactly how the magic of
the Faceless Men works, but by wearing Walder’s
face, Arya takes his appearance and voice
and everything, and she uses this disguise
to gather the Freys at a feast.
She talks of the Red Wedding, when the Freys
killed Arya’s mother and brother and others.
And then, with poisoned wine, Arya kills the
Freys, sparing only the women.
This revenge was a long time coming, and Arya’s
clearly pleased with her work – but is this
really justice?
The main people behind the Red Wedding – Walder
and Tywin and Roose, and Lothar and Black
Walder – they’re already dead.
Were all these Freys really guilty, and deserving
of death?
There’s a similar thing in the books where
Catelyn is resurrected as Lady Stoneheart,
who mercilessly kills all the Freys she can
find – but it’s not really clear if the
people she kills are all guilty – she even
tries to hang Brienne and Pod.
So Stoneheart makes us question whether violent
vengeance is right.
And similarly, Arya’s killing is questioned
when she runs into Ed Sheeran and his Lannister
mates.
This is a humanising scene where a bunch of
nameless redshirt soldiers show that they,
too, have personalities and families and dreams.
They are Lannister soldiers, they’ve probably
done bad things – but Arya realises they
still deserve to live.
Maybe the same was true of some of these Freys.
Arya’s arc has made her a ruthless killer,
but she’s still capable of mercy and humanity
– and that’s one of the themes of this
episode – justice and vengeance versus mercy
and compassion.
After the intro, a dark fog roll in, with
the Night King and white walkers leading the
army of the dead, which includes a few undead
giants.
This giant is missing an eye so some fans
think it’s the corpse of Wun Wun who died
at Winterfell.
But Wun Wun lost his right eye – this guy
his left eye – so it must be some other
one-eyed giant.
Twelve-foot-tall zombie giants are pretty
scary, and in the books, there are also undead
bears and birds and “things in the water”,
and “ice spiders”, even rumours of ice
dragons.
Maybe we’ll see some of these this season.
Also, it’s cool to see the darkness brought
by the white walkers.
Cause the walkers aren’t just frosty blokes
who like the cold and the dark, they bring
the cold and dark, they kinda are the cold
and dark, they are winter.
The walkers might be connected to this world’s
irregular seasons.
So maybe the seasons will become normal after
the walkers are defeated.
If the walkers are defeated.
One their great opponents is Bran, now called
the three-eyed raven cause he’s got psychic
powers and shit.
He arrives at the Wall with Meera Reed, and
Ed of the Night’s Watch lets them through.
Some people thought that this mark that the
Night King made on Bran last season might
let the white walkers pass through or break
the Wall when Bran enters, but it looks like
the Wall’s still standing – for now.
At Winterfell, King Jon Snow holds a meeting
with the north.
He says they gotta get dragonglass to fight
the white walkers – because dragonglass
kills white walkers.
And he sends Tormund and the wildlings to
defend Eastwatch – one of the castles on
the Wall.
For centuries, wildings have attacked the
Wall – but now, with a common enemy, the
wildlings and the north stand together.
Jon says that all northerners, including children,
will join in the war against the walkers.
Robett Glover and Lyanna Mormont argue over
whether girls should be allowed to fight,
and it’s decided that children of both sexes
will join in the war.
It’s crazy how in a world like Westeros,
gender equality can mean conscripting ten-year-old
girls to fight and die against zombie hordes.
Jon and Sansa argue over whether the Umber
and Karstark families, whose leaders betrayed
the Starks for Bolton, should be allowed to
keep their castles, or be replaced.
Littlefinger enjoys seeing Sansa and Jon divided
– but Jon decides to keep the old families,
and accept oaths from their new young rulers.
Alys Karstark has a plot in the books about
Jon helping her deal with her uncle, while
Ned Umber is a character invented for the
show – cool how he has this cross on his
clothes, though, representing the Umber chains
– the older Umbers wore something similar.
Sansa and Jon talk afterwards, and basically,
Jon’s a decent ruler, but could benefit
from Sansa’s advice.
Over the last six seasons, she’s learned
politics from the best – or, you could say,
from the worst.
Jon mostly learned from his uncle Ned – who
is a great bloke, but lost his head cause
he was too dumb – or too merciful maybe
– to survive.
The Starks get a letter from Cersei, who demands
that they come south and kneel.
There’s a long history of Starks coming
south and dying there – Rickard, Brandon,
Lya, Ned, Robb – so it’s smart of Jon
and Sansa to stay put.
Cersei is a problem, but it’s the walkers
who threaten all.
At the capital, Jaime and Cersei Lannister
chatona map.
Cersei talks about how she hates Tyrion – who
she believes killed Joffrey – which he didn’t.
And that he killed Tywin – which he did.
In the books, there’s a prophecy that Cersei’s
brother will kill her.
Cersei thinks this means Tyrion, but some
readers think Jaime – go watch that video
. Cersei also reveals her feelings about her
son Tommen, who committed suicide last season.
It was kinda weird how calm and cold Cersei
was about Tommen’s death.
Now we learn that she feels that Tommen betrayed
her, by going over to the Faith.
You’d think she’d feel grief that her
son died alone and confused and afraid – but
Cersei hardens her heart against Tommen.
If this is how she treats her son, just imagine
how she’ll treat her enemies.
As Jaime points out, things look bad for the
Lannisters – Cersei’s surrounded.
Daenerys is invading from the east, with her
allies in Dorne and the Reach.
King Jon’s in the north.
And with the death of Walder Frey, the Lannisters
have no allies left.
So Cersei decides to make a new friend – King
Euron Greyjoy.
Euron sails in to King’s Landing, with his
red eye on the ironborn ships.
In the books, Euron’s ship is called the
Silence.
It’s crewed by “mutes and mongrels”
, painted red to hide the blood – and when
men see his sails, they pray . In Season 6
of the show, some people felt Euron was kinda
boring.
Just another gruff bearded white bloke who
shouts a lot.
But now, Euron’s different – more expressive
and colourful and nutty – like a peanut
M&M.
A bit more like the Euron of the books – though
not as sorcerous or scary.
Jaime feels insecure that this black-clad
Jack Sparrow is hitting on his sister, so
he reminds Euron of some old family beef – the
Greyjoy Rebellion.
Bout ten years ago, Balon rebelled against
the crown, so the rest of Westeros got together
and put him down.
Which was pretty sweet – a young Robert
and Ned and Stannis and Tywin and Barry and
Thoros and Gregor and Jorah and Jaime all
fought together against the Greyjoys.
The Greyjoys lost of course, but “What is
dead can never die” and now’s Euron back,
offering his hand – both hands – in marriage
to Cersei.
She says no, but he says he’ll return with
a gift – so what’s he planning?
Cersei did just mention how much she hates
Tyrion, and Tyrion has been offered as a gift
to a queen before, so maybe Euron has eyes
on the dwarf.
In Oldtown, at the Citadel, Sam’s weighing
brains and stacking scrolls and scooping soup
and scrubbing poop.
Game of Thrones Hogwarts is not as fun as
he thought it would be.
He came here to learn secrets that would help
in the fight against the white walkers, but
no one here seems to believes that they even
exist.
Archmaester Ebrose assures him that every
other time someone thought the world would
end, it didn’t.
But Sam has seen the threat is real, so he
breaks into the restricted section of the
library, just like Harry Potter, to find something
to help against the walkers.
This might relate to something that’s happening
in the books, when Jaqen H’ghar breaks into
the Citadel – go watch that video . But
in the show, Sam gets a book about dragonglass,
the stuff that kills white walkers.
And he learns of huge caves beneath Dragonstone
full of obsidian – which’ll be super duper
useful against the white walkers.
For the record, Stannis already told Sam about
that dragonglass , but who listens to Stannis,
right?
Later, we find Jorah is at the Citadel, suffering
from greyscale.
Dany ordered him to find a cure, remember.
And it might just be that the book Sam found
could hold the answer.
This page mentions “dragonglass as a cure”
for “illnesses and dise[ase]”.
It mentions “ingestion”.
So maybe eating dragonglass can cure greyscale?
It would be weird if the same stuff that created
white walkers – who can make icy zombies
– can save people from greyscale – which
makes stone zombies.
There’re lots of different types of zombies
in Thrones – maybe they’re all related
somehow.
One other thing – this knife on this page
about Valyrian weapons looks just like the
catspaw’s knife, that Littlefinger used
to frame Tyrion.
The same knife that Arya wears on a magazine
cover.
It’s not clear what the point of this will
be – but it sure looks like this dagger
is important.
It’s only Episode 1, and Sam’s already
making discoveries.
Back at Winterfell for a moment, Pod gets
his ass beat by Brienne, and Tormund wishes
it was him.
Petyr creeps on Sansa, but she swiftly shuts
him down.
Littlefinger used to be an amazing schemer
with a complex plot in the early story – now,
he mostly hangs around and says snide shit.
He’s gonna have to do something if he’s
to survive this season.
We then get a scene with the coolest new squad
in the story – Thoros, Beric, and the Hound,
Sandor Clegane.
They stay at a farmhouse, and Sandor has been
here before.
In Season 4, the Hound and Arya stayed with
a farmer and his daughter here.
Sandor mugged the farmer, said they’d die
by winter, but now when he finds them dead,
he shows regret, and pays his respects by
burying them.
The act of gravedigging refers to a bit in
the books where, after his apparent death,
the Hound becomes a monk and digs graves as
penance for his sins – a peaceful end for
the character in the books . In the show,
the Hound’s wars are not over, but the point
of the gravedigging seems the same.
Sandor used to be a remorseless killer – remember
when he killed that kid Mycah in Season 1?
But now he has some humanity and respect for
life.
Back when Sandor hung out with Arya, he was
always the brutal one, while she wanted mercy.
Now it’s the other way round – Arya remorselessly
slaughters, while the Hound mourns the dead.
How will these guys get along if they meet
again?
Sandor Beric and Thoros talk about destiny,
and god.
The Hound overcomes his fear of fire and looks
into a flame, seeing a vision of the marching
dead by a castle where “the Wall” meets
the sea.
So that’s Eastwatch, where Jon sent the
wildlings – and in the books, Melisandre
does predict that the dead will attack there.
But Sandor also sees “a mountain” that
“Looks like an arrowhead”.
It’s not clear what this means.
The mountain could mean a place like the Fist
of the First Men, or the obsidian at Dragonstone
, or a symbolic mountain like the Hound’s
brother Gregor, or a zombie giant maybe.
And the arrowhead bit could mean dragonglass
arrowheads, maybe?
It’s hard to say.
But one thing is clear – the dead are marching
on Eastwatch.
The final scene is something that readers
have waited for for decades.
Twenty years ago, the first book came out,
and ever since fans have hoped to see Daenerys
arrive at Dragonstone.
Her home, where she was born, where her ancestors
the dragonlords lived for centuries – and
the starting point for her campaign to take
the Throne.
There is a sweet seat, and Stannis’ banner,
and sand is rough and course, and it kinda
makes no sense that the castle is empty.
But the significance of this scene is as the
beginning of the end, the start of the final
act in the story of Game of Thrones.
Thanks for watching.
Subscribe for a new video for each episode
every week.
You can also support this channel on Patreon
. We’re holding livestreams after each episode
– answering questions and talking Thrones
– if you wanna join in, become a Patron
at the link below.
Thanks to Patrons Lewis hennessey, Jessy Saville,
Bill Miller, Randy Wirth, Amanda Wernicke,
François Bernard-Sévigny, Amy McDermott,
and Dirk.
Cheers.